[Música]
la actualidad más destacada del
continente africano está en france 24
bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días comenzamos
con los titulares en kenia el tribunal
supremo confirmó la victoria de william
ruto en las elecciones presidenciales
del 9 de agosto su rival a raila odinga
había impugnado los resultados
denunciando supuestos fraudes
un alivio para el cuerno de áfrica la
semana pasada un barco llegó al puerto
de yibutí con un cargamento de trigo
para etiopía donde el hambre amenaza a
millones de personas debido a una sequía
histórica en el norte del país
y cada vez más programas de reality
shows se abren paso en las pantallas de
varios países del continente pretenden
combinar cultura y entretenimiento para
sensibilizar sobre temas sociales como
el aborto la violencia machista hablamos
con el director de uno de estos
programas en senegal
comenzamos esta edición en kenia donde
el tribunal supremo falló a favor del
ganador de las elecciones del 9 de
agosto william ruto en una demanda
interpuesta por el líder opositor raila
odinga por presunto fraude electoral
tanto odinga como roto ya se han
pronunciado por la decisión judicial y
acogen el fallo sin embargo el líder
opositor insiste en que la dirección de
ruta fue fraudulenta ampliamos en el
siguiente informe de samuel salgado
el pronunciamiento de la máxima figura
del tribunal supremo de kenia que
pretende poner fin a días de tensión
política en consecuencia declaramos la
válida la elección de william bruto como
presidente electo de conformidad con el
artículo 143 de la constitución
el fallo el tribunal confirma la
victoria del ex vicepresidente y ahora
presidente william ruto en las urnas el
pasado 9 de agosto jornada electoral
empañada por un manto de dudas por
posible fraude electoral el rostro más
visible de los cuestionamientos raila
odinga líder opositor y segundo en
votación se ha presentado cinco veces a
la presidencia del país africano y en
varias oportunidades ha alegado fraude
electoral como en 2017 cuando la
comisión electoral confirmó que hubo un
intento de hackeo al sistema de conteo
esta vez odinga afirma que un equipo de
trabajo es muy bien bruto habría
pirateado el sistema electoral para
cambiar la visualización de los
resultados lo que llevó a odinga a
presentar la demanda de la que hoy se
conoce el fallo su abogado respeta la
decisión del tribunal pero la califica
como sesgada el líder opositor aseguró
que acoge la decisión judicial
si los tribunales deciden lo contrario
básicamente respetaremos la decisión de
los tribunales
mientras que el electo presidente hizo
un llamado a la unidad de todos los
sectores políticos out y por lo tanto
extiendo una mano de hermandad a todos
mis competidores y a sus partidarios no
somos enemigos somos kenianos unámonos
para hacer una nación en la que todos
estemos orgullosos de llamar hogar
en kenia es considerado como el país más
estable de la región y como un aliado de
occidente en conflictos vecinos como el
de somalia pero actualmente la nación
enfrenta una enorme deuda y un
encarecimiento de alimentos y
combustible esto sumado a la histórica
disputa étnica que también es causa de
la rivalidad entre william bruto y raila
odinga
seguimos hablando de elecciones en
angola el partido de la oposición unita
ha anunciado que presentó un recurso
para impugnar legalmente los resultados
de los comicios legislativos que dieron
la victoria al partido gobernante y por
lo tanto un segundo mandato al
presidente joão lorenzo en el poder
desde la independencia de portugal en
1975 el movimiento popular de liberación
de angola el mtl obtuvo el 51 17 por
ciento de los votos en estas elecciones
que estuvieron marcados por una
participación muy baja votaron menos de
la mitad de los 14 millones de personas
registradas unita obtuvo el 43 95 por
ciento de los votos recordemos que en
angola no hay elecciones presidenciales
y que el líder del partido ganador de
las elecciones legislativas es investido
como jefe de estado escuchemos el
titular del partido de la oposición
en un día 24 de agosto hubo botón a
mudanza el 24 agosto que el pueblo votó
por el cambio es por ello un interés sus
socios del frente patriótico unido no
reconoce los resultados finales
publicadas esta semana por la comisión
electoral nacionales ya que no reflejan
la verdad elector acción al electorado
porque éstos no reflect la verdad y
electoral hoy se colocó expectativa de
que el comité hoy habló con la esperanza
de que la comisión electoral nacional
así como el tribunal constitucional
desempeñen realmente cotizaciones en
estricto cumplimiento de la constitución
porque la ley es la constitución y ex
leyes
23.000 toneladas de trigo ucraniano
llegaron al cuerno de áfrica tras el
acuerdo firmado el mes pasado entre
ucrania y rusia para desbloquear las
exportaciones de grano un barco el brave
comando llegó con su cargamento de
cereales al puerto de yibutí con destino
a etiopía país que atraviesa una sequía
histórica
él braid commander salió del puerto
ucraniano de pits denny el 16 de agosto
dos semanas más tarde llegó al puerto de
yibutí con 23 mil toneladas de trigo que
deberían aliviar algunas de las
necesidades alimentarias de etiopía el
futuro de los alimentos del break como
ander alimentarán a 15 millones de
personas durante un mes en etiopía así
que esto tiene un impacto muy
significativo en aquellas personas que
actualmente no tienen nada el programa
mundial de alimentos podrá ahora
satisfacer sus necesidades básicas basic
nights un acuerdo firmado en julio entre
kiev y moscú con la mediación de turquía
en la onu facilitó la salida del gran
ucraniano bloqueado por la guerra entre
rusia y ucrania el cargamento del barco
será transportado desde yibutí etiopía
según el programa mundial de alimentos
vende los millones de personas están en
peligros en el cuerno de áfrica debido a
una sequía histórica la peor en al menos
cuatro décadas etiopía somalia y kenia
se ven afectadas la ausencia de cuatro
temporadas de lluvias desde finales de
2020 ha terminado con millones de
cabezas de ganado
destruido los cultivos la organización
meteorológica mundial de la onu ha
advertido que la próxima temporada de
lluvias entre octubre y diciembre será
insuficiente
la sequía que estamos viendo en el
cuerno de áfrica es la peor en más de 40
años calculamos que 22 billones de
personas se enfrentan a graves problemas
de hambre lo que supone una necesidad
humanitaria muy muy importante
y por supuesto también hay conflictos
por lo que la situación en el cuerno de
áfrica es muy grave es muy importante
que declare el grano in cráneo para
aliviar el sufrimiento de las personas
ucrania y rusia se encuentran entre los
mayores exportadores de grano del mundo
cuyo precio se ha disparado desde que
comenzó la guerra según el centro de
coordinación conjunta que supervisa el
corredor marítimo para la exportación de
cereales desde los puertos ucranianos ya
han salido del país por mar más de 721
mil toneladas
además de la sequía en el cuerno de
áfrica el continente sufre otras
consecuencias del calentamiento global
como las inundaciones en varios países
entre ellos nigeria y sudáfrica con este
telón de fondo se llevó a cabo en
libreville capital de gabón la semana
africana del clima una de las reuniones
preparatorias de cara a la cob 27 que se
celebrará en noviembre en egipto áfrica
vive las consecuencias más devastadoras
del calentamiento global a pesar de que
sólo es responsable del 4 por ciento de
las emisiones globales de co2 además con
recursos limitados niveles de ayuda
internacional muy bajos el continente se
ve obligado a gastar el 3% de su pib
anual para adaptarse a los impactos de
la crisis climática
varios líderes denuncian una injusticia
climática global según ali bongo odimba
presidente de gabón el objetivo de la
reunión fue hablar con una sola voz en
nombre de áfrica
a propuestas concretas en la cob 27
hablemos ahora de cultura una isla
desierta a orillas de un río en senegal
y alrededor de una gran hoguera una
veintena de mujeres están inmersas en
debates sobre el aborto y la violencia
de género este es el trailer de reina de
áfrica on reality shows ilegales que
dice querer escuchar a las mujeres del
continente
combinando cultura y entretenimiento
para saber más sobre este fenómeno al
alza en el continente hemos hablado con
patrick mendi y director de otro chico
sep la empresa audiovisual que está
detrás del programa reina de áfrica le
pedimos que nos presente su programa y
que nos explique en qué se diferencia de
los reality shows habituales
necesitan del ente
panafricano que de fondo se trata de un
reality show panafricano al que reúne a
mujeres de 18 a 28 años en general yo
diseñado por una empresa audiovisual se
realizan
diferentes pues que nace para
este 'reality shows' a diferencia de los
demás porque no destaca a la mujer como
un objeto sino que intenta dirigirse a
los jóvenes
y al público en general a nivel
educativo cultural y social
[Música]
y social con el fin de revalorizar a la
mujer africana a través de estos tres
aspectos fundamentales promover el
liderazgo femenino y devolver la voz a
las jóvenes para que participen en la
vida pública en general
ante este panorama tiene un concepto que
difiere de otros reality shows que
suelen mostrar los concursos de belleza
nosotros a través de la cultura africana
que es un motor de reunificación de
unión a través de los valores
tradicionales africanos e intentamos
promover los podemos luchar contra la
discriminación social especialmente lo
que llamamos discriminación de género
debe incluir discriminación social se
obtuvo con la androide de nosotros
cuando el de la discriminación puede ser
pero no sólo son dos canciones las bolas
de 'break' con el concepto así que en
general estas son las líneas principales
de nuestro concepto y también hay otra
parte las candidatas son candidatas que
al final una de ellas será la ganadora
mente alzaba la caña con un discurso
social
defenderán causas sociales en cuanto a
educación salud temas como el derecho al
aborto o la violencia con las mujeres
de los efectos de tontos únicos que son
remotos en áfrica son causas que
realmente son un tabú en áfrica y
trataremos de concientizar a todas las
poblaciones africanas de que esto puede
cambiar tanto jurídicamente como en
cuanto a las creencias o las diferentes
formas y modos de aceptación que las
poblaciones tienen en esta violencia
mañana dijo mañana de muerte de
aceptación con de compilación de sesión
esto así termina el programa de esta
semana pero quédense con nosotros porque
la actualidad internacional continúa en
france 24 y france 34 punto com
[Música]